my crazy but true uh harrowing tale I
guess of how a father can be removed
from his home in handcuffs put in jail
forced through
um five incarcerations and permanently
separated from his sons all because of
one false allegation in in family law
there is no due process there is no
presumption of innocence that the burden
of proof should be on the accused rather
than the accuser we have a system of the
Salem Witch Trials four thousand
children every day lose a parent in
Family Law Courts in America and when
you look at the states being
incentivized they get six thousand
dollars for every child they Place into
foster care there are bonuses awarded if
they move those children through to
adoption we have to take the incentives
away you know we hear a lot about
prenuptial agreements but we don't hear
anyone talking about prenuptial custody
agreements we put more cachet on our
material possessions and our financial
estate than we do our children we need
to look at these systems that are in
place and and really try to call out
those on the other side who are
incentivized and make all of the money
the tens and tens of millions of pounds
in the UK and dollars
in America to further their agenda which
is to keep the money in family court and
keep separating parents from their
children
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constance and this is
a show for you if you want honest
conversations with Fascinating People
our brilliant guest today is a
best-selling author TV director and Emmy
nominated actor Greg Ellis welcome to
trigonometry it's great to be here chaps
how are you oh we're very well mate it's
great to have you on the show uh let's
get straight into it you you have a very
interesting story to tell and in some
ways a tragic one I would say so tell
everybody how are you uh where you are
what's been your journey through a life
that leads you to be sitting here
talking to us
gosh that's a great profound question uh
well I was raised and toughened I guess
in the seaside fish and chip shops and
Smoky uh video game arcades of uh Rough
and Tumble Southport in Northwest
England
um mastered the Rubik's Cube at 12 held
the record for Pac-Man at 13.
um and then at 14 15 I did a broad I'm
not a West End Musical and um you know
my journey through the entertainment
business four decades in the
entertainment has included acting voice
over I've done over 130 video games uh
cartoon animation directing producing
and then
um authoring three books in my third
book The respondent was born out of a
personal situation a personal tragedy uh
2015 March 5th
um my crazy but true uh harrowing tale I
guess of how a father can be removed
from his home in handcuffs put in jail
forced through
um five incarcerations and permanently
separated from his tons all because of
one false allegation so in essence the
what I call the cartel of family law my
book the respondent uh exposing the
cartel of family law showed up on my
doorstep on March 5th
um stole my freedom I kidnapped my
children or father napped me and and in
essence destroyed or murdered my family
and it sounds like a Hollywood movie
trailer for a psychological Thriller but
it's not it's real life and it what I
discovered through my journey through my
dystopian Kafka trap journey through
family law was that it's happened to me
and it's been happening to hundreds of
thousands of people for decades decent
law abiding citizens Across America the
UK Australia South America Canada and
um judges attorneys State Bar
associations mediators psychologists
none of them want their dirty little
secret to get out which in America here
it's a hundred billion dollar a year
industry so that um really is the the
kind of grounding place for the
responder.com my book
um my show the respondent uh the movie
that we're going to be making the
documentary series we've started making
to just really have an impact and maybe
improve the system that doesn't afford a
presumption of innocence in the one area
of our legal system that really should
have it first and primarily and that's
family law
and the fascinating thing about it was
and I said tragic as well is when I was
reading it I became a father for the
first time like six months ago like I
cannot imagine that pain that you had to
deal with being separated from your
children uh and to that's just one
aspect of it your credits were Pirates
of the Caribbean Titanic you worked on
some huge things and you are
defenestrated in public too uh in prison
Etc or incarcerated you know
let's just tell us more about first of
all how did that happen like what was it
like what happened
yeah I was at home uh I'd actually taken
the afternoon off it was a Thursday I
was reading uh reading books my sons in
the playroom of my house uh in Hollywood
and um the doorbell rang and it was that
simple the doorbell rang and I walked
down the stairs and told my boys would
be back up with a little puppy at the
time and I opened the door and little
did I know that that would be the last
time that I would open the door in my
own house and what had what had happened
was was a 10 word false allegation that
was made
um on an Anonymous hotline which I've
since discovered this tactic of What's
called the quote-unquote welfare check
is what's used Across America anyone can
call anonymously and say uh by hearsay
that someone has threatened to take
their own life or they're threatened to
hurt themselves or their children and
the police not only are legally bound to
show up they're legally bound without a
warrant to enter the home and violate
privacy and due process rides through
Miranda rights nothing and and so that
was the beginning of my dystopian
Odyssey if you will of how I was
handcuffed removed from my home
incarcerated the sudden and shocking
removal from everything in my life my
um my livelihood my um my money my car I
didn't even have a phone and within
within the space of a few hours I became
homeless and almost destitute and um my
entire life was turned upside down and I
was very grateful that a few people you
know stuck in there and helped me
through uh through that Journey because
it was psychologically physically and
and emotionally just just terrifying it
was like living on the edge of
existential angst really and um you know
I talk about this on my show The Living
grief of alienation from one's own
children when they are the meaning of
your life and you love them so much and
you're so connected to them and you
would die for them into suddenly and
shockingly be removed and deal with that
pain and also so I think the pain of
knowing that your sons or your children
or your daughter are removed from their
connectivity to to the meaning of their
life their parent particularly such an
emotionally connected parent as I was
and Greg what were these 10 words that
uh you were that made up the accusation
am I allowed to swear yes okay whatever
you want oh great the ten words were
um I'm sick of this [__] I'm gonna harm
the children and they were the 10 words
that were reported to the police that I
had reported allegedly said which I had
and I would never say those words and
even if I did I wouldn't say them that
way
um and those ten words became the kind
of the gateway to you know welcome to
family law and I thought as well those
10 after after I was incarcerated and
this went to court and I entered the
legal system I ignorantly thought that I
would get some justice finally you know
the establishment of Justice would
provide some fairness and what I found
was it was the Star Chamber it was the
wild west of family law
what do you mean by that the wild west
of family law because I've had friends
actually who've been in similar
situations you're not as extreme but
certainly similar and you're using terms
like wild west of family law there's a
there's a few people who are probably
thinking I don't know what that means so
just explain it to us please Greg sure
so you know the in in family law there
is no due process there is no
presumption of innocence
um parents are found guilty till proven
innocent or usually guilty to proven
more guilty particularly fathers it
happens to mothers as well
um and criminals get more rights than
children and parents terrorists
murderers pedophiles so if you if we
have a legal system that doesn't afford
due process that that says that the
burden of proof should be on the accused
rather than the accuser we have a system
of the Salem witch trials and the
Spanish Inquisition in 2022
so how did that play out in your case
Greg because I I think that uh forgive
me but for someone from your perspective
with your experiences to put it mildly
to you you you kind of get all this but
I think the average person and I include
myself on this by the way we're all
walking around with absolutely no
[__] idea what you're talking about I
I genuinely think that right yeah so so
you people come to your home because
your now ex-wife has made this false
allegation against you
um
the police take you away what happened
how does the whole system work
well basically what's what happened with
me is and I first of all I want to say
yes absolutely I agree I had no idea and
I say this to my you know I founded a
charity CPU children and parents United
and I say to my team and the volunteers
who work with me on the respondent
movement
um that we have to get the message out
to the people who the versions of us
before we got hit by this system
um the people who don't really I didn't
really know and I didn't really care
because they didn't know I three days
before it happened to me on March 2nd I
I was putting my boys to sleep as I did
every night and my eldest said you know
so and so at school's parents are
getting divorced you'll never get
divorced with your daddy and I said no
of course not I mean it was 20 years I
was mad who never expected or blindsided
um but in terms of
the question which I forget because I
went off on a tangent what was the
question the question was once she the
police are at your door oh that's right
yeah they take you away and what because
this is my point is I don't think anyone
really knows what that what happens then
you talk about lack of due process and
these are all legalistic terms yeah like
what happens so basically the reason why
they can get away with doing this is
number one it's a welfare check it's
it's in essence it's a fake welfare
check that's called in anonymously the
police arrive they know they're entering
the home regardless of what you say or
do and I help I was at stood at the
threshold of my home for about 90
minutes trying to have a polite
conversation with these two police
officers that became three four five and
eventually a Garrison and they entered
the home then the smart team uh the
psychological gestapo of the social
workers in California came to interview
me and determine not knowing me not
knowing my history whether
um I was of sound my mind and body then
I and that was while I was in handcuffs
with the curtains wide open and all the
lights blaring so all the neighbors
walking by and looking in and then I was
removed in the back of a um unmarked
police car with my 10 year old son
looking down from the bedroom window
seeing his father being dragged away in
handcuffs for the last time that I would
be at home
I was taken to
um uh UCLA Reagan Medical Center which
is like hospital
no one was giving no one gave me any
information as to what was going on I
kept asking it was a harrowing ride I
was forced to do a drug test which was
negative I remember looking in the
mirror of the hospital restroom and just
I was so
um overcome I guess that I collapsed and
I'm lying in the pool of blood on the
floor
um and then I got and then I got
re-transported by the smart team the
back of the the hospital to these two
big Burly
um men who handcuffed me into a gurney
and put me in the back of a what I call
an ambulatory rehearse but it was just
another kind of ambulance that wasn't
connected to the hotel I took to the
hospital and um and the doors were
slammed and then the next I guess it was
about 75 minutes in the dark I was just
lying there in a gown handcuffed to a
gurney not knowing why I was there where
I was going and what would happen
and then I mean I could go through the
whole story but it's in the book
um that's but then
you realize you know I look back I
wasn't I've never been arrested so it's
a detainment it's a legal detainment and
they can determine whether you go it's
called a 5150 hold which is three days
um and you get you get incarcerated you
get put away in a in a psychiatric
hospital and people who knows just to
clarify Greg this can literally happen
to anybody you can be taken because of
an allegation made anonymously by
telephone and overnight your life
literally changes you put in handcuffs
and you can be detained in a psychiatric
unit
correct and and it and it was so it's
three days initially now that's if
that's if you you are calm and compliant
like I was you know in that conflict
situation where law enforcement are
entering your home violating your
privacy you could be doing anything it's
your own home so you the forced conflict
of the welfare check can cause people to
be agitated frustrated sometimes people
get violent so some people can get
arrested and it can just they can just
get put in the system and it can ruin
their life well in my situation it was
three days but then three days became 14
because my ex-wife and mother-in-law
came and they talked with the doctors
and the the psychiatrist said after a
conversation with them we've decided to
extend your stay to 14 days that's when
I started to get I how what's my plan to
get out of here how can I get my freedom
back because I'm stuck in this
psychiatric hospital
um and what reason did they give you
Greg for being stuck in that psychiatric
hospital did they diagnose you with
anything did they say you had some type
of Personality Disorder no they don't
have to give you a reason they don't
have to give you any reason whatsoever
um and no there was no diagnosis I mean
I actually in my book I put there's two
psychological evaluations by
psychiatrists that the court ordered me
to go through uh independent evaluations
I actually published them in my book one
from 2015 and one from 2019 so that it
would be fully transparent that I was
not psychologically Disturbed I am not a
mentally imbalanced person in fact part
of my work is to help people going
through this who are having
psychological and mental health
challenges
so that happens what happens after that
you're in there for 14 days obviously
you're not in a good State you're not in
a positive frame of mind you can imagine
just say the least yes
if anything's going to induce some kind
of uh negative psychological State it's
the experiences that you've been put
through exactly and just to clarify I
wasn't in there for 40. they extended my
state of 14 days I managed to get out of
the six days so not going through all
the stories that are in the book or deep
diving in essence what happened was like
there was a very friendly nurse that I
that I managed to speak to and she gave
me the kind of pathway out two options
you can apply to have a hearing in front
of a judge that could take two weeks etc
etc or an immediate hearing so I had an
immediate hearing and um it was
basically just like sitting with you
know
um communist China really because they'd
already determined that they were going
to keep me there
um the social worker who was part of the
the the the the the psychiatric facility
um just repeated the words that I was
reported to have said which were
anonymously said as a false allegation
um but I made a I made a decent enough
case that I was told if I could find an
address they would let me out and of
course then I had no money to make a
phone call I didn't have access to money
I didn't have a phone there was one pay
iPhone thankfully the patients there
actually had a whip round because the
doctors that do these classes and then I
would do I'd talk and try and help some
of the patients there while I was inside
to find something positive and
productive from being in there so I
managed to I mean look the phone calls I
made
I didn't have a phone number so I had
these coins and there was a pay phone
and I'm thinking well I don't have a
phone number to call
so um my ex-wife inadvertently and
mistakenly brought a script uh because I
was I was at the time looking at movies
to direct and this script had my Agency
phone number at the bottom and I was
like oh I'll call them and it was late
at night and I spoke to the bless this
assistant I mean I spoke I called the
agency spoke to him and I convinced him
to go into my iCloud and get go get find
my contacts and so I'm grabbing a pencil
a piece of paper and I'm literally
scribbling down while the money's
running out on one phone to get phone
numbers then I start the phone calls to
a few people and there were two painful
pay phones so I'm just kind of juggling
one and hang on so-and-so's calling and
and I must have sounded absolutely nuts
as people are picking up the phone that
haven't heard from me in a week
There's four circulation I know
psychiatric I mean that's what it does
to you to your point it just it makes
you
nuts wow wow so I mean
to me that is that's like you say it's
something I have a dystopian thriller so
how do you get out of that impossible
situation that you find yourself in well
it's you know the the book kind of uh
really goes into detail on that but you
know to give you an idea of how I I
eventually managed to get out of that
um that facility or hospital and
um that was after six days and
um and then of course how did your
friends react because this is one thing
that I always think about in this
situation because look if Francis or our
producer Anton calls me up I'm like I
know these guys so well like whatever
but a more distant friendship you're
going well how do I know what's happened
you know you're telling me it's a false
allegation I wasn't there I mean maybe
you are about to you know Murder your
children I don't want to be giving you a
I don't want to be putting you in the
spare bedroom next to my kids
well that's the thing is that you don't
you don't get the opportunity to tell
people when you're locked away and have
no access and communication to the
outside world is completely and utterly
shut down I mean I came out after six
days and I was
I went to a neighbor's home who agreed
to let me stay and I stayed and as I
left it was like well I didn't even
leave I was on the phone to my ex-wife
and it was a ruse to keep me on the
phone unbeknownst to me there were like
10 or 12 police officers outside as if I
was some kind of international terrorist
banging at the door I opened the door I
get dragged out handcuffed again my
mother-in-law at the time marched down
the street my street where my house was
down the road and served me a
restraining order and I walked into
homelessness
um and there was a slight twist there in
terms of I was handcuffed and I think
they were going to take me away because
I had one of those the sergeant was one
of those sergeants you know what I mean
um and this big six foot three hulking
massive black man stepped out from the
bushes and said sorry can I talk to you
and I was like what's going on and they
had a couple of minutes chat and then
the sergeant came back and released me
and I walked into homelessness and this
guys sort of Lumbers down the streets
that someone's looking out for you
they've been watching you uh you have to
come with me I just I was so in the days
it's like I kept walking I was all I was
thinking about park bench oh my God I'm
here I've worn the same clothes for six
days I didn't have a phone I didn't have
money I didn't have credit cards or a
wallet I didn't have a car
um and I looked smelled and was homeless
and I'm going
I'm I'm going to be in sleeping in
streets
and this black guys no you've got to
come with me you got to come with me and
it turns out
that um I had one I mean I had a few
friends that that stuck by me because
you know you find out who your friends
are Integrity is earned in turmoil not
really asserted in comfort and um and it
was a wonderful fellow uh called Adam
Fogelson who happened to be uh at the
time the chairman of Universal Studios
uh very very powerful fellow in
Hollywood but he knew who I was he knew
my character I I known his family for
years and taught his daughter when she
was five six seven years old how to
um like we'd go over as a family every
Sunday morning and I teach you how to
play piano and write songs and perform
and it was just kind of like a friendly
family thing and he I arrived at his his
house around 5 30 in the morning looking
just a mess and um I think uh he had he
had actually employed a security company
to
um to track the police scanners because
they knew at some point I would find a
way to get out and they also knew that
the police and what my ex-wife and her
uh
mother and her mother's ex-husband who
is a federal Marshal and I mean it was
all stacked against me they'd come and
get me and I'd be served and I would be
going down whatever way I go down in the
Kafka trap and um he he was able
actually his wife was able to negotiate
um my wallet
um and my car and phone from my ex-wife
because he felt it was just inhumane to
leave me homeless all right so she kept
hold of of literally your card your
wallet all the rest of it so she had
possession of it when you were taken
away yeah I had nothing I had absolutely
nothing can I ask you what I'm sure is a
very unpleasant question but it's a
question that a lot of people listening
to this will be uh at some level
thinking about when we're having this
conversation like you know how people
are there's no smoke without fire what
did you do you know because that's how
people are right people assume that you
had so why did you expect life do this
hey Francis if you were a member of the
public would you like the opportunity to
ask incredible guests like Bill Burr
Jordan Peterson Sam Harris Adam Carolla
Brett Weinstein John Barnes Douglas
Murray Nigel farage and Lionel Shriver
your own questions you bet I would and
what do you think the best way to do
that would be uh probably stalking mate
you'd have to Corner them in the
supermarket probably around near like
the sort of frozen food of and then just
bought questions at them before they can
escape not the American ones as they
have guns and you'd have to be extra
careful with the females as that's how I
got in trouble last time do you really
imagine you're gonna get Douglas Murray
near the frozen food aisle if you want
to ask our incredible guest questions
and have access to phenomenal behind the
scenes content then you have to be on
our locals that's right for only seven
dollars a month you get incredible extra
content behind the scenes footage
giveaways and also the chance to be part
of an incredible Community where you can
meet and hang out with like-minded
people you get access to our American
Vlogs as we travel across the country
interviewing Our Heroes an extra 20
minutes of our viral Sam Harris episode
as he discusses his approach to covert
we're also going to start doing
giveaways of exclusive trigonometry
merchandise like this a poster from our
Edinburgh show signed by both of us and
also a House of Lords Teddy which you
can only get in the House of Lords
signed by the one and only baroness Fox
locals also gives you access to an
incredible online community you can
share memes talk about the latest
episode or even make a new friend or
just one exactly more than both of us
have really people are now doing meetups
in their City because they love locals
in fact some people enjoy it so much
they prefer it over the show they prefer
locals to trigonometry
if I have to get them executed I'm the
one that goes to jail right go to
trigonometry.locals.com only seven
dollars a month for all that incredible
content
trigonometry.locals.com See you there
guys
so why did your ex-wife do this
yeah that's a that's a really good an
important question as well and as as
much as I've you know thought this
through
um I think
she suffered from panic disorder she was
diagnosed with panic disorder it was a
it would rear its ugly head occasionally
and and for anyone who who has to endure
that uh very painful diagnosis there's a
new rationality about things that come
up I remember one time taking her to the
airport and what should have been a 35
minute drive took two and a half hours
and we never made it to the airport
um you know irritable bowel syndrome
um go home there's the irrational fear
so she I know for a fact that she'd been
off her but she'd not taken her
medication for a while
um and I think and she was out of town
and I think this fear um just came up
instilled in her uh from maybe from a
few coincidental events and she
um she made that that call and
um you know one of the things that I'm
I'm really clear about uh even though
even to this day she uh uh she's on a
mission to to ruin me
um seven and a half years later
um is that I don't have any hatred
towards her for what what she did and
what she continued to do
um you know I say there's a lot you know
we forgive others because they sometimes
because they not because they deserve
forgiveness but we deserve peace and
forgiveness is not a line that we take a
road that we cross it's not necessarily
I forgive our actions but
um she's the mother of my sons and um
you know they will eventually
come to realize after their psyches were
split between mum and dad and they were
told all these horrific stories about
the dad that they knew up until the ages
of eight and ten there was a you know a
connected loving playing
um volunteering emotionally supportive
dad and then just got eviscerated and I
think after the fact look to be full
disclosure it's all in the book you know
I don't paint myself out to be some kind
of you know a brilliant
um husband I was a brilliant father I
can say that without hesitation I was a
brilliant and am a brilliant father
um I was a good husband but I was a
little flawed
um and I think after the fact what
compounded it was that um I I disclosed
and in my booktube that I wasn't a
faithful husband and and that I think
um probably compounded or gave a reason
for more Vengeance
um and revenge and anger you know so
and what was the impact on the children
because this I mean
what they must have been going through
must have been absolutely awful
particularly at such a tender and young
age
yeah it's this is one of the things I
mean I talk a lot about the false
allegation of domestic violence which is
I call it the Silver Bullet of high
conflict divorce and the magic
ballistics of family law or family law
War but what they what what children
endure
um even when it's not so acrimonious is
Parental alienation and parental
alienation is is AKA child abuse it's
also known as turning the children it's
an umbrella term that details a series
of actions if you will or behaviors with
the malicious intent to have the
children hate a once beloved parent and
there are signs of that isolation and
gatekeeping and psychological splitting
like the presence of a prior positive
relationship between the child and the
now rejected parent there's uh you look
at the absence of maltreatment or
seriously deficient parenting on the
part of the now rejected parent or the
lack of ambivalence in the child's view
or seeing one parent is all good and the
other is all bad criticism I mean simple
things like criticizing the the other
parent in in front of the children or
limiting contact by interfering with the
other parents time if there is a divorce
or there are two homes so this this
aspect of it this aspect of the
psychological they're very challenging
aspect of any divorce with with children
involved particularly minor children but
any children is something that isn't
talked about in the UK not only is not
talked about it's a whole like movement
and lobbying group of radical feminists
who who deny the existence of Parental
alienation who want to bring laws
through it you know I heard about law a
couple of years ago maybe 18 months ago
I was going through the House of Lords
that was um domestic violence against
women and girls so it wouldn't protect
baby boys or five-year-old boys or men
you know in the rates of Ip ipv intimate
partner violence are clear when you look
at the statistics it's 52 48 men on
women and 48 52 women on men so it's
almost even there you know domestic
violence and abuse has no gender but we
very rarely talk about it with men
because or violence on men because well
men are kind of devalued and Expendable
for the most part smash the patriarchy
you know they're toxic don't you think
Greg to be fair as well is that we you
know we have you know we can cause more
damage to women physically than they can
cause to us therefore it's not taken as
seriously when a woman is physically
violent or abusive yeah I absolutely
agree I mean you know relationship I was
in after my marriage you know there was
some uh physical abuse uh connected I
think you know Nikki correct did a study
at the Minnesota Minnesota University on
on behaviors and movements towards
quote-unquote violence and yes men have
a tendency to move to violence quickly
and it's physical and you know go any
Pub in England or most pubs in England
on a Friday night and they might go when
I was when I was growing up they'd be
the fights and then you know 10 minutes
later you could be sitting at the at the
at the bar having a drink and getting
over it whereas what she deemed she she
actually deemed the term reputation
savaging which is why I use a lot I know
a lot of people say reputation
destroying but she said women move
towards a a reputation savaging of
violence with the words gossip the
spoken word the hintega Dank and the
thought in the back of the mind that
comes out through
um that gossiping about someone and
sharing stories about people I sort of
say all women don't want to be you know
yeah I mean the problem is is that you
then put the court system which is not
only a drain emotionally but it's also a
drain financially and listening to you
and reading your book this the odds are
stacked against men if they're
fundamentally biased aren't they
yeah I mean there's no two ways about it
if you are a man if you are a father
it's harder if you're a father who's the
respondent in family law they have you
know what you what you would call a
petitioner and a respondent the
respondents really the defendant
um if you were a father respondent uh
and you become the respondent if you
don't file first and if you know the
petition of files first and gets um uh
and is represented retains an attorney
you are forced into what I call the
divorce trap where you will go bankrupt
you have no uh you know ability to stop
um it becomes worse because you have two
attorneys who are trained to make
arguments against each other in America
you can't have one attorney it's illegal
to have one attorney and two people uh
come together to to to negotiate through
and find settlement that's why with my
with my charity you know we're looking
at things like we have a tech team
that's looking at an app uh to bifurcate
and shift the jurisdiction away from
family law into contract law in essence
micro contracts along the the way and
the pathway and the history of a
relationship that can that can basically
contract these mini contracts along the
way so that if there is a Fallout
disagreement and divorce is imminent it
can be dealt with in in contract law as
a business rather than the wild west of
family law
but look there's going to be people
listening to this going your story is
awful it's tragic no one should have to
go through that but there are also cases
and we witness them all the time it
happens in the UK it happens in the
states where a dad for whatever reason
has some kind of psychological break
kills a wife kills the kids
awful we hear about them those stories
all the time
do we not need to be extra cautious in
order to therefore protect and to ensure
that that event doesn't happen in order
to protect the lives of children yeah we
absolutely do well absolutely absolutely
we do and we also have to hear about
that when it's mothers who do that and
there are many stories they're not in
the news as much when mothers do that
human beings parents have pressure
everyone's struggling with something and
many people who live in lives of quiet
desperation and when that happens the we
need to be aware and the legal system
look I have
I have someone who works with my charity
who 22 years ago was was falsely accused
and sat in court and held his wrists up
to the judge and said your honor please
arrest me have the bailister bailiff
arrest me and charge me with a criminal
offense and the judge said are you crazy
and what he went on to explain was he
gets more rights as a criminal he wanted
to be arrested he wanted to have the
right to have an attorney domestic
violence should be tried in Criminal
Courts an extremely serious offense and
the allegation of which should be taken
seriously but just like not believing
any group of people just because they
make an accusation like believe all
women Preposterous we should listen to
people take them seriously and
authorities and law enforcement should
investigate and interview and take
statements but unfortunately the
immediacy of what happens if there is an
incident where it used to be you know
we'll let it blow over there's a cooling
off period now that doesn't happen
particularly in places like California
in the cost to our children and costs to
us is crazy and when you look at Family
Law
four thousand children a day four
thousand children every day lose a
parent in Family Law Courts in America
and when you look at the states being
incentivized they get six thousand
dollars for every child they Place into
foster care there are bonuses awarded if
they move those children through to
adoption we have to take the incentives
away
and we we really have to I think address
what was school shootings and
incarceration rates with men and drug
abuse and teen pregnancies we have to
look at the farthest fatherless crisis
and the dad deprivation crisis I think
that's going on because one in three
American kids live without their
biological father in the home and
they're at greater risk of having more
difficulty in their lives according to
just about every metric out there no and
Greg I was going to ask you because I
think
um I don't know how the family law
system became this way and I don't
understand the intricacies of it but one
thing I've noticed culturally is we had
an organization I'm sure maybe still
exist called fathers for justice here in
the UK and the only reason I know about
it is it was a punchline in every
comedian set a few years ago and and
that is kind of how we we treat it and I
have always thought you know I do cringe
a little bit when you get sort of men's
rights movements and and whatever and
that's because I think and see what you
think about it
no
statistically speaking men are less
important uh biologically right if you
have a tribe of 10 women and 10 men and
you lose half the men it's not a big
deal you lose half the women your
ability to reproduce the tribe
significantly impacted right so
biologically speaking men are more
disposable and therefore I think as
people we don't have the same empathy
for men and their problems as we do for
women now what does that mean that means
that victimhood
is not going to work for men right it
just isn't what I think you'll you'd
agree with me on that yeah absolutely
well this is the new social currency and
its economies booming yeah but but not
for men if you try to say look this is a
male problem and we all accept that the
problems that women face and they do
need to be tackled that automatically
means that there will be problems that
men face invariably right but we don't
think about it like that in our society
we think we've got these victims on the
one hand and man well you know they've
got privilege and their abusers and
they're a threat and all of this and
they're disposable so so I suppose the
question for me is how do you overcome
that because raising awareness of the
fact that there are people like you
who've gone through the awful
experiences that you've gone through
eventually Vindicated after a terrible
ordeal
well yeah
well you know yeah you you pers from a
personal perspective you do the recovery
work you know you look in the mirror of
mirror of self you have that inevitable
appointment with yourself but look I'm a
Caucasian
um middle-aged somewhat heterosexual
male actor from you know England who's
worked in Hollywood for nearly three
decades what are your pronouns
[Laughter]
I'm not no comment
so you know I I get you know I knew
going into this that there would be a
lot of attacks and there'd be a lot of
vitriol and you know
um man hated me being a mansplainer um
you know we'd hear a lot about equality
and to your point it's like we don't
hear the you know woman's planer we
don't hear like we should have anyway
I'm not gonna go there
um it's a great question let me go there
before you answer great because I had an
interesting experience
um a few years ago uh where my wife uh
who who was she she was really into
break dancing at the time and she went
to a break dancing class and as one of
the things that they were doing she need
herself in the face and she had a black
eye for two weeks and I tell you what
man walking around with her
for two weeks in public completely
changed my perception of this issue
because I guarantee you the looks I got
and some of the [__] that people would
openly say
you know we went to a restaurant and
this woman looked at us and went well he
didn't do that too did he
[Music]
um
you know and the looks people would look
at her then look at me with an angry
face and then walk away it's like you
don't know anything about me you've just
you've jumped to that conclusion because
it's a stereotype but it's okay because
some people are okay to stereotype yeah
there's a great short film I forget
um it's about it's from a charity uh in
the UK actually and I've played it a
couple of times on my show it's only
about three minutes long but it was a
social experiment and it's out in the
park and it's very busy lots of people
and the man starts berating the woman
and you see people coming up and you
know talking to this blow what do you
think you're doing who you get leave her
alone and then they do the same thing
roll reversal with the woman doing the
same thing to the man pushing him up
against the fans and and berating him
and it Snickers and laughter and
derision so um but I do think there is a
slight cultural shift I don't think
there'll ever be a full cultural shift
in terms of what I do look I talk about
men and women fathers and mothers the
extended family how it affects that how
alienation you know I've Speak to spoken
to a lot of grandparents you know
they're truly innocent suddenly when
there's a divorce and there's alienation
is acrimonious they're removed from
access to their grandchildren in the in
the you know the latter stages of their
lives and the effect that it that it's
having on our children
um look I don't know if we'll be able to
reform family law in my lifetime we can
we can improve it we're making strides
to improve it and you know I'll get the
attacks
um but ultimately the victories come
um uh very meaningful and in terms of
boys I think that's for me you know
don't don't girls and women want boys to
be you know better off and more
well-behaved and
um socially you know uh in a good place
and I look at schools I mean that to me
is the education system I mean it's
predominantly populated by by female
teachers these days and it's moved over
the past 30 years to cater to the
natural behavior of girls and that boy
behavior that maybe we were more into
growing up like playing war and being
more rambunctious that was considered
boyish is now considered problematic and
you know I think psychology and Child
Development expert I think his name's
Michael Thompson yeah he says that girl
behavior is the gold standard now in
schools and boys are treated like
defective girls so you know I had
Christine Christina Hoff Summers on my
show she's um the American Institute
American Enterprise Institute
philosopher and she wrote an article
school has become too hostile for boys I
think it was for Time Magazine and and
she mentioned Elementary and high school
Zero Tolerance tolerance regimes uh mean
boys account for 70 of suspensions from
kindergarten through 12th grade so no
one's really getting out there and
talking to people like Dr Warren Farrell
and others you know you mentioned the
men's Rights Movement as well you know I
had a few of those groups contact me
early on when I was beginning my quest
to see how I could put together this
this project this multimedia project and
there is a sense sometimes and I get
where it comes from when you look at
what what some men go through through
and fathers go through of anger and
resentment and this inner rage you know
and I don't think that works when we're
having the conversation you know we've
got to include mothers and daughters as
well as you know fathers and and Sons
well you you talk about father absence
and by the way Warren Farrell is the guy
who we've had on the show and I think
his book The Boy crisis and and many
other things he talks about uh and
particularly given his own background of
being like one of the first male
feminists in America or whatever it was
like he he's got a lot of credibility
and I think the things that he says are
very apt but the boy crisis the
fatherhood absence all of that uh that
is a bigger thing than even the
conversation we're having here because
the impact on society out of that is
just it we all know I mean we all know
the statistics of the impact that that
has on children particularly boys but
also on girls
um and I suppose the question is where
you think that comes from because if you
if you take uh you know take Thomas Saul
thomasaul says well it's you know the
welfare state in the 60s but I don't
think that's necessarily the only
explanation because it's not just
happening in America right uh you talk
to someone like our former guest Louise
Perry I think she'd probably say well
the breakdown of the family comes from
the sexual Revolution you change the
roles of men and women around the same
time that's what happens what is your
take on where you think you know the
breakdown of the family at the scale
that we are seeing now is just
unprecedented where does it come from
well that's a that's a big question I
mean you know Professor Janice fiomingo
talks about feminism she says feminism
is the reason for it um you know in its
entirety uh I'm not saying that
um I think this
probably in enough trouble as it is
um I think there's many reasons I think
you know if you look at the marriage and
divorce statistics
um you know 41 of all marriages will end
up in divorce we talk about
um you know we hear a lot about
prenuptial agreements but we don't hear
anyone talking about prenuptial custody
agreements we put more cachet on our
material possessions and our financial
estate than we do our children
um you know 43 percent of of children
grow up without their fathers 90 of
divorced mothers are awarded or have
custody so until we start valuing the
mail them the patriarch and The
Matriarch and you know I've said it for
a while now I think the greatest threat
to Western civilization is the breakdown
of the family unit and we we hear about
these and I'm not particularly some you
know uh right-wing you know Republican
like gung-ho no no no no no no you are
now don't worry about it people are
pretending yeah once you start having
any wrong opinion about any issue you
you become right-wing it's like us
neither of us is right wing but you
start talking about controversial stuff
you become right-wing so just get a gun
uh start eating red meat you know
whatever else you're supposed to move to
Alabama yeah exactly yeah get the best
well just you know I didn't leave the
left the left left me but um yeah and
answer to your question I think one of
them is is child support okay I call it
the child support hustle and it's the
size of the machine it's become they are
debtors prisons where abolished you know
the death is prisons were abolished over
a hundred years ago yeah child support
arrears can incarcerate a parent
um Walter Scott I think it was a case of
Walter Scott maybe eight ten years ago I
wrote about this he was he was a guy who
was shot in the back eight times by by a
white police officer and um you know no
one in the in the Press talks about what
led to why he was pulled over with a
broken tail light and ran he was running
because five I think four or five times
he'd been put in prison for child
support
he couldn't afford to pay that three
thousand dollars for a man on on you
know thirty thousand dollars a year
maybe earning that on the poverty line
the real poverty line then it gets hit
with that by the state and that and then
there's interest on top of that so and
then you look at thirty percent of men
paying child support and not the
biological father so I think there's the
child support hustle where poor non-con
non-custodial parents who lack the
ability to pay child support end up in
this modern day debtors prison
um and the system of punishing parents
uh works for the courts it works for the
legal system the attorneys and the
cottage industry of people who work
within it what it doesn't work for is
our families our future Generations our
parents our parents parents our extended
families and particularly our children
it's conflict oriented it's about abuse
argument and alienation it's about
prizes the cash prizes putting cash and
profit over over parents and children
it's about money control and hatred and
acrimony rather than really truly
understanding a family first model which
is the best interest of the child and
parents love and co-parenting child
centered and providing more of a
peaceful future and I think we have to
look at the CPS as well the child
protection services I don't I don't say
it lightly when I say when I ask the
question who's kidnapping children to
sell into foster care I call the CPS
racketeers
um you know that they for decades now
and it's startling when I found this out
for decades children have been removed
intentionally from their homes seized
from their families and parents snatched
kidnapped legally traffic for profit all
due to legislation introduced in 1974
it's the adoption and safe families act
which offers Financial incentives to the
state that increase adoption numbers so
tens literally tens of thousands of
children are and have been and will
continue to be taken from homes that are
safe
for the purposes of garnering federal
funding and state funding and that fraud
and of course it's usually the the
parents who can least afford to
um to to retain an attorney
or don't have the financial you know
wherewithal all the smarts to be able to
navigate the system
um we need to look at these systems that
are in place and and really try to call
out those on the other side who are
incentivized and make all of the money
the tens and tens of millions of pounds
in the UK and dollars uh in America to
further their agenda which is to keep
the money in family court and keep
separating parents from their children
Greg I'm sure that there are people who
are listening to this or watching this
and they're in this situation they're
going through this what advice would you
give to them
gosh well first of all I'd say I I
relate you're not alone I mean I wrote
my book for a multitude of reasons and
started this project for a multitude of
reasons if you are listening or watching
and you're going through this you're not
alone you're not crazy you're not mad
um and
I try not to give advice in a general
sense I've written a compendium free
downloadable ebook called the code for
those who want to go to
therespondent.com and that is for
immediate interventions into well-being
and it offers some uh psychological tips
uh I guess somatic remedies
um for individuals who are suffering
through the trauma of this system
because it's so traumatic
um it just rips the very meaning of your
life away your children it's extreme
it's shocking it's unrelenting it's
inescapable this divorce trap and how
people can can endure what I call the
living grief I mean I've spoken to a few
I know a few people I call it suicide by
living grief there is a finality when
someone dies and we are we go through
the grieving process
um but parental alienation and suddenly
being removed from one's own children
is a living grief that is difficult to
describe if you haven't been through it
so all I would say is you know there are
there are programs that my charity is is
you know offering and building out
um part of part of that is communication
programs workshops and programs to
promote and improve interpersonal
relating how we can better communicate
with each other uh mediation uh
Solutions oriented intervention experts
that help resolve uh conflict and not
um not propagate it and rack up billable
hours to keep people out of the court
system so if you're thinking of getting
divorced if you're thinking of retaining
an attorney if you're thinking that you
need to go to war don't that's what I
would say and if you are stuck in the
system
there is hope and there is a way out it
may take a while but um hopefully people
will find the respondent and find ways
to you know get relief families need
relief from being Shipwrecked and in
this horrific system and Greg we left
your journey uh at you getting help from
an influential powerful friend how did
you yourself get to a point where you
are now where you're doing all this work
and uh you I can tell from the way that
you are that emotionally you've
processed all of this as well and you've
got to a place that is now constructive
and you are out in the world doing
things uh rather than stewing on on the
on the experiences that you had what was
the process from where we left you uh
how did you how did you manage to you
know get get
not you didn't get justice but
Vindication at least and and freedom and
so on
well that's a great question I think in
terms of the details of the the kind of
dramatic inciting incidents by the book
I know I know no no no I'm not no no I'm
not I'm not doing it to kind of you know
to promote it I'm saying because we'd be
here too long we're talking about it no
I appreciate it but yeah but no the
answer I would give is is basically a
year more or less a year after I was you
know because it went on for about five
and a half six years it was that long
um I sat down one night I mean I did a
lot of self-reflection work and I
studied with people I have mentors I
studied affect Theory phenomenology
um psychology
um and got to know myself and this
system a lot better but I sat down and I
asked myself the proverbial Socrates
question who am I I wrote it in my notes
on my iPhone and I went into a deep dive
dialectic and I'd never done that before
um and I asked a meaningful question
that got a meaningful answer and and it
was kind of thesis and uh anti-thesis
and then synthesis and each
synthesis gave me a new meaningful
question I had 1100 notes and meaningful
answers within an hour it was like you
know biohack brain brain flow that the
artist goes into I guess
um and that really helped kind of
solidify where I wanted to go who I was
uh how I was going to become a better
human being a better man an even better
more improved version a way more
improved version than myself and
transcend who I used to be break through
those commonly held belief systems that
I had before and Enlighten myself
and um you know just share my story as
as the vessel really for so many other
stories that are out there
um for people to be able to and I still
do the daily work you know there are
rituals that I have I talk to people
about yawning which isn't because you're
tired you want to release emotional
energy from the emotional container of
the body you give yourself a hug and you
rub yourself because that's somatic I
talk about Peter Levine's work waking
the tiger
um getting into a conversation with the
organism and the body getting outside of
cognition because affect Theory teaches
us that there are things happening in
the biology of the body that that inform
the biography of the stories that we
tell ourselves and make up and so we can
reshape and redraft those narratives
that we've grown up with from an early
age and become a more mature I guess
more consistently mature human being
Craig I'm going to ask a question it's
going to sound provocative but I I think
it needs to be asked would you ever get
married again
gosh that's a really great question I
think for a while
um
for a for a long while it was it was no
um in terms of contractual marriage I
you know I I believe that the union if
you will and The Vow that one makes and
the commitment to another is so
important so whatever religion whatever
spiritual practice whatever
um belief system you have
um like do that but in terms of the
legal marriage contract I don't think
that that I've looked at this there was
nothing to be gained and everything to
be lost from the contractual part of
that
um so the simple answer is yes I mean I
bought
seven years ago I bought a really nice
white shirt when I could when I had some
money again and it's still in the
wrapping seven years later and that's
the white shirt that hopefully one day
will wear
um for my wedding ceremony of Union to
whoever and whomever
um that that person is if and when I
find oh [__] well let me tell you as a
man who's about to enter my forties you
only need to go you're gonna need to go
to the gym quite a lot just to be able
to fit into that shirt after all these
years my friend
Greg listen it's been great to have you
on and uh thank you for sharing your
story with us uh you like I say for me
as a new parent particularly it's just
imagining what you went through I I I
can't and and it's it's crazy and I
really commend you for being able to
talk about it in the in this in the
healed way I can tell that you've you've
really processed it
um and that's why you're able to talk
about it the way you do so tell everyone
buddy before we ask you our last
question for the main interview and
before we do our locals only uh bit uh
tell us
where we can where people can buy the
book where they can follow your show
where they can find your work great yeah
and in response thank you for having me
on I mean you guys do a great show and
uh you know you are you you are all
about the Civil discourse
um
you alt-right Nutters
what is it I forget all the terminology
all right Neo-Nazi oh whatever
yeah well you know it doesn't stop
people from saying that so yeah well I
appreciate I appreciate it yeah no
therespondent.com is the kind of home of
the respondent where there's a lot of
information information on the charity
CPU uh is at therespondent.com as well
children and parents United is the
charity
um there's also my book the audiobook of
the of the book uh there's the
respondent community uh which is a safe
space for parents who are going through
this who have gone through this or
grandparents or family members and
that's on the mighty networks and
there's all also I haven't really made
the announcement yet but there is uh
we're going to have the respondent world
convention on April 21st in Las Vegas
and we're going to bring together some
great experts and practitioners as well
as some great entertainment to come
together and bring a little Joy back
into people's lives as well as some
information and remedies Dr Warren
Farrell is going to be there as well as
many other people and Trauma Specialists
so looking forward to that
fantastic Greg and the last question we
always ask is the same what's the one
thing we're not talking about that we
really should be I well I think we've
just talked about it but um you know
really I think this conversation about
family law and our our familial bonds
our familial tapestry is so so vital
um in this day and age with the age of
modernity and technology and how we're
kind of the the device dependency and
the reverse psychology of the algorithm
of social media is how we can more
particularly for younger Generations
because it's not their their
responsibility we're the ones that raise
them we are the older generation how we
can find those remedies and reliefs uh
from I'm not suggesting people tune out
from your show obviously from your
typical social media
um uh dopamine hits and addictions
um so I you know I think
if I were to select one thing within
that kind of umbrella because to your
point it's if we improve family law I
think would improve every part of our
physical health mental health
incarceration rates drug rates teen
pregnancies online team porn addiction
etc etc is
well I'm in America so I would say
school shootings
um I think we we talk a lot about the
horrific uh sadness and the gun debate
and when it enters our school with our
children that safe space as parents
where we leave our children for the day
every day for many days and many weeks
of the Year what's causing that and for
me it's lack of fathers it's lack of
mentoring bringing back the mytho poetic
talking more about the rich qualities of
man the masculine fathers and that
hunter-gatherer and bringing back those
Rites of Passage that seem so lost are
still there in so many great religions I
mean the the Catholicism Judaism you
know that they're there but with the
crisis of meaning and the crisis of
faith I think that's been going on we
really just need to to to start
championing man a little more and boys
rather than vilifying them
I couldn't agree with you more the fact
that men and women have somehow I talk
about this in my book as well to some
extent the fact that men and women have
been positioned as uh enemies as opposed
to people who have to collaborate as
they have done throughout the entirety
of human history uh to build and create
things together in harmony uh it's
mind-boggling and it is like you say
it's one of the biggest threats to
Western civilization so it's been a real
pleasure to have you on we're going to
ask you one or two questions from our
local supporters that only they will get
to see the answer to but for now Greg
Ellis thank you so much for coming on
the show and thank you all for watching
and listening we will see you very soon
with another brilliant episode like this
one oral show all of them go out at 7pm
UK time and for those of you who like
your trigonometry on the go it's also
available as a podcast take care and see
you soon guys
what's going on with the movies Greg why
are they all crap now
[Music]